when a beloved actor dies millions of
people who didn't even know them grieve
in their own way but for their co-stars
showing up to work without the person
you've been acting alongside for years
is tragic he rose to prominence while
starring as Finn on the musical sitcom
Glee but in 2013 Cory Monteith passed
away after battling with addiction since
his teenage years the entire cast
struggled to deal with the loss
especially his co-star Lea Michele whom
he had been dating at the time of his
death Michele said that eventually not
acting was more painful than getting
back in front of the camera she wanted
to be surrounded by the Glee cast again
after all she and Monteith both thought
of the rest of the cast and crew as
family plus she said that Monteith would
not have wanted her to give up on her
passion Michele explained on The Ellen
DeGeneres Show at the end of that year
there is an empowerment that comes with
grief at some point you find it it's
very hard but you will find it and I
think at a certain point you can choose
to sort of fall from this or you can
choose to rise and that's what I'm just
trying to do my best for him because I
know that that's what he would have
Michelle still keeps Monteith's memory
close she recently got a new tattoo that
says Finn she post tributes to him every
year if anyone you know is having
suicidal thoughts please call or chat
online with the National Suicide
Prevention lifeline at 1-800 to 73 talk
that's one eight hundred two seven three
eight two five five four years Bob
Einstein played Marty funkhauser on the
long-running hit HBO comedy Curb Your
Enthusiasm catching Larry David in
countless gaffes in January 2019
I'm Steen sadly passed away after
battling cancer the death of Einstein
shocked and saddened the cast David said
never have I seen an actor enjoy a role
the way Bob did playing Marty funkhauser
on Curb it was an amazing unforgettable
experience knowing and working with him
there was no one like him as he told us
again and again fans will undoubtedly
miss his iconic gravelly voice and the
humor he brought to the show despite the
tragedy Jeff Garlin told The Daily Beast
that they will not bring
Einstein's death during the show's 10th
season because he said there is no
melancholy on Curb Your Enthusiasm
basically they're not planning to kill
off the character but there's a good
chance that they will reference him in
some way it might be the kind of episode
that makes you laugh even while you shed
a tear Bea Arthur and Betty White worked
together on the hilarious NBC sitcom The
Golden Girls
which featured a group of over 50 women
living together and finding humor in
their old age there were always rumors
of a feud simmering between Arthur and
white but the co-star rue mcclanahan
insisted that at the end of the day
they're supposed Feud really came down
to artistic differences
McClanahan explained B came from a New
York stage point of view she always had
what we call the fourth wall and Betty
came from a television point of view she
would flirt with the audience and pull
up her skirt and say hi sailor but B
never acknowledged the audience when
Arthur passed away in 2009 white was as
heartbroken as any diehard Golden Girls
fan after her death White said I knew it
would hurt
I just didn't know it would hurt this
much yes Arthur and white would butt
heads behind the scenes occasionally but
underneath it all these two actresses
had great respect for each other and
Arthur was greatly missed when Disney
Channel star Cameron boys passed away
after a fatal seizure it was a harrowing
wake-up call for his co-stars Boyce died
young he was only 20 he should have had
an amazing life and career ahead of him
his descendants co-stars couldn't
believe that he was gone dove Cameron
who played Maul and considered Boyce a
close friend said that his death
reminded the cast just how precious life
is in the wake of his passing The
Descendants cast members were going out
of their way to spend more time together
Cameron told enews he just was
everything that everybody says he is he
he was from someplace else
Cameron also got a tattoo to remember
Boyce she chose a design with a flower
coming out of a gun an international
symbol for peace and anti-war movements
dated that boys was working with an
organization against gun violence before
his death and she wanted to memorialize
him as someone who cared deeply about
peace as Luke Skywalker and Princess
Leia Mark Hamill and Carrie Fisher
inspired a generation of sci-fi fans who
fell in love with their Star Wars
characters when the franchise was
revived with the force awakens in 2015
legions of fans were thrilled to see
them return to their roles and bring the
story to life for a new generation of
fans but when Fisher passed away in
December 2016 Hamels view on the film's
changed there's no doubt that Hamill
loved Fisher and he cherished their
friendship for life however her death
affected his memories of Star Wars and
he didn't have much motivation to return
for future films Hamill told ABC news in
2018 rather than being sorry that we can
have more of her I'm just grateful that
we had the time with her that we did of
course Fisher did appear in the rise of
Skywalker via archived footage and
Hamill made one last cameo as Luke's
force ghost bringing the Skywalker saga
to a close after 42 years John Ritter
played Kaley cuoco's father on the
sitcom 8 simple rules for dating my
teenage daughter and while they weren't
actually related he still felt like a
father figure to her his untimely death
due to complications with a heart
condition left her feeling lost and
today she still thinks about him all the
time
Cuoco couldn't believe that Ritter was
gone and the cast addressed his death in
a touching episode of 8 simple rules
KOCO continued moving forward in her
acting career Landing a major role as
penny on the Big Bang Theory but she
never forgot about her wonderful
experiences of working with Ritter on
the 15th anniversary of his death in
2018 she revealed that there isn't a day
that goes by when her memories with
Ritter don't make her laugh at the same
time she still mourns his loss her Big
Bang Theory co-star Jim Parsons said I
don't think she ever talks about him
without tears in her eyes she's
emotionally stable but there was
definitely a fatherly bond when fans of
Riverdale and Beverly Hills 90210 got
the news that actor Luke Perry had
passed away after having a stroke they
were devastated and his former co-star
shannen doherty took the loss on a deep
personal level Doherty had worked with
Perry on Beverly Hills 90210 where the
pair played longtime love interests
although the original show had ended
years before Daugherty was still
devastated by Perry's death he had
supported her through thick and thin and
stood by her side when she was fighting
cancer when the 902 1o reboot was
announced Dougherty originally did not
plan on going back she did not think
that the show really needed her but when
she got the news about Perry's passing
she had a new perspective she decided
that she would return for the reboot
after all and it would be the perfect
way to keep his memory alive
the actress revealed when Luke passed
away things drastically changed for me
and I felt like it was a great
opportunity to honor him and I'm really
glad I made that decision because now I
get to sit up here with a lot of people
that I respect and love
sadly actress Debbie Reynolds passed
away only one day after the death of her
daughter Carrie Fisher fans of both
women couldn't believe the news and
Debra Messing who played Reynolds
daughter Grace on the sitcom Will and
Grace knew that her life would never be
the same
from the moment Messing met Reynolds she
was struck by her bold presence Messing
told Entertainment Weekly Debbie was
really indescribable she would come on
stage and she was abroad in the greatest
sense she always was entertaining and
singing and dancing and she was running
off and doing a one-woman show you know
300 days of the year it was just crazy
Messing always looked up to Reynolds and
she knew that they couldn't let new
episodes of the Will & Grace revival go
by without taking the time to honor
Reynolds the writers created an episode
about Grace wanting her father to hold
on to her childhood home rather than
selling it because she didn't want to
lose those memories of her mother now
she still posts occasional tributes to
Reynolds it's clear that she will never
forget the time they spent together on
set Alan Rickman was known for many
different roles but millions of people
knew him best as Severus Snape in the
Harry Potter films when he passed away
in early 2016 fans of the series were
heartbroken he brought this character
from the books to life he played the
sinister role so well that it was hard
to believe he was such a kind and funny
man when the camera wasn't rolling just
take it from Daniel Radcliffe who grew
up playing Harry
Potter alongside Rickman Radcliffe
explained in a statement after the
actor's death as an actor he was one of
the first of the adults on Potter to
treat me like a peer rather than a child
working with him at such a formative age
was incredibly important and I will
carry the lessons he taught me for the
rest of my life and career Radcliffe
said that Rickman has always supported
him whether he was working on a movie or
a play and that he wouldn't be the actor
he is today without Rickman's guidance
when Paul Walker died in a car accident
his Fast and Furious co-star Vin Diesel
lost a best friend after Walker's death
diesel visited Walker's mom her house
was his first stop after hearing the
news diesel shared on Facebook
his mother hugged me and said I am so
sorry I said sorry you're the mother who
lost a son
she said yes but you lost your other
half while filming Furious 7 diesel
admitted that shooting the barbeque
scene at the end of the film was very
emotional in fact he had to step away
for a few moments because he just
couldn't believe that Walker wasn't
there on set with the rest of the cast
diesel told USA Today I had never done a
barbeque scene without him and I just
cracked and broke down and had to walk
off set to collect myself that was the
only time I wasn't strong enough to keep
it together but the entire cast and crew
wanted to make sure that they paid
homage to Walker throughout the film
finishing production with the help of
the actors brothers and ending the story
with a touching tribute to the departed
comrade Harold Ramos and Bill Murray
were an unstoppable comedy duo they work
together on films like Ghostbusters and
stripes and it seems like everything
they touched turned to gold
sadly the pair had a serious falling-out
while working together on Groundhog Day
they didn't speak for over two decades
after sometimes in interviews Ramos
would admit that he missed their
friendship and that he hoped they could
be friends again one day for the longest
time it looked like they would never
reconcile but when Murray found out that
Ramos was on his deathbed everything
changed his brother convinced him that
he had to go visit Ramos Murray listened
and the two finally made up upon his
death Murray reminisced on their many
achievements together Murray said Harold
Ramis and I together did the National
Lampoon show off-broadway meet
stripes Caddyshack Ghostbusters and
Groundhog Day he earned his keep on this
planet god bless him superhero films
haven't always earned glowing critical
reviews particularly in a pre-2008 world
but Christopher Nolan's Batman Begins
sequel The Dark Knight was an exception
Heath Ledger played the Joker to
Christian Bale's Batman and although
both actors were lauded for their
performances Ledger's take on the Joker
truly stood out Vale had a great respect
for Ledger's talent he was truly a
gifted actor and that was perhaps never
more evident than it was in Christopher
Nolan's game-changing epic when Ledger
died several months before the release
of the film Bale was shattered
he told parade he was somebody who died
been seeing on a daily basis for months
it takes a long time to accept that
someone's gone when all body and mind
are telling you that this is somebody
you will know for a great deal of time
he was something of a kindred spirit to
myself Bale was disgusted by the way the
media covered Ledger's death and he
hoped that people could move past it and
view his work on The Dark Knight as a
celebration of his life it seems like
bales wish came true it came as a
surprise to no one when Ledger
posthumously won an Oscar for the role
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff for coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you
[Music]